et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
david guiraud porte-parole jeunesse de
la france insoumise en soit david
guiraud merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés une philippe bouyer sénateurs l
ère des deux sèvres porte parole de
valérie pécresse soit on vient de voir
les français dégustons matière de
pouvoir d'achat si je reprends la
question centrale du débat est
évidemment une formule très célèbre
rendu célèbre par mitterrand en 81 13
sur le show m'adresse qu'on a vraiment
tout essayé pour le pouvoir d'achat
david biraud mais moi je pense que le
gouvernement prend les français pour des
abrutis en nous expliquant alors là
c'est les chiffres récents donc
le niveau de vie augmente et donc moi
j'aimerais bien savoir honnêtement
j'aimerais bien savoir on a perdu deux
ans de croissance les plans de
licenciements auraient explosé l'adresse
me dis plus de mille plans de
licenciements la vie est plus chère sur
de nombreux produits je pense aux
produits aux produits frais +2 4% le gaz
l'électricité plus de 12%
toutes les autres évaluations
précédentes qui ont mesuré un peu les
effets de la politique d' emmanuel
macron sur sur les français montrent que
par exemple et 5 % les plus pauvres
hyper tandis que les plus riches eux
voient leurs revenus exploser et qu'en
fait dans cette espèce de tripatouillage
statistiques il ya que deux choses qui
sont sûr c'est que les milliardaires et
les plus riches de ce pays se sont gavés
ils ont gagné près de 175 milliards
d'euros entre mars et décembre 2020
c'est à dire en pleine crise et que les
français y survivent et ils survivent et
la seule chose qui leur a permis de ne
pas avoir la tête complètement sous
l'eau c'est quoi ces les mesures point
arraché les gilet jaune c'est des
mesures concrètes de pouvoir d'achat
mais même ça même ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on a distribués aux français mais
qu'on va le reprendre dans l'avenir
parce que par exemple sur les mesures
d'âge il est jeune c'est 3 milliards
d'euros qu'on a fait envoyer dans les
comptes de la sécurité sociale et qu'est
ce qu'on est en train de nous dire
aujourd'hui ça coûte trop cher la
sécurité sociale et un trou il va
falloir faire des coupes dans les
dépenses de la sécurité sociale donc
tout ça et est une embrouille pour les
français et moi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec cette manière de faire de présenter
pour le gouvernement car rien tout va
bien tout va bien alors les gens ont
faim il y en a un sur un français sur
cinq qui sauta repas mais tout va bien
et a foncé sur cinq qui dit avoir du mal
à
payer sa facture énergétique mais tout
va bien bas nombre je suis pas d'accord
alors c'est vrai que cette petite
musique
elle revient dans dans vos commentaires
on va le voir un sandrine c'est eux
le message précédent effectivement cette
petite musique retour de lier cette
chasse à la fraude fiscale
adama papers sont combien de milliards
déjà 11 milliards trois cent mille ou
nous dit
cet internaute augmentation du smic
n'hésitez pas à rappeler que la france
compte aujourd'hui 2 millions de pauvres
vous êtes d'accord avec cette opposition
confère en permanence les pompes de plus
en plus pauvres les riches de plus en
plus riches et rien n'a été fait pour
les plus modestes dans ce pays alors je
nuance près de dix années de trop face
on me donne façon générale on voit bien
que l'écart s'est agrandi entre ceux qui
étaient les plus riches et ceux qui sont
les plus modestes on le constate et on
voit à travers les chiffres notamment
lorsqu on fait l'analyse de toutes les
mesures sociales d'accompagnement ça
c'est un constat en même temps malgré la
situation difficile de l'aide de la
crise qu vide on voit bien que
l'économie aussi repart et qu'on a des
capacités d'emploi de progression en
matière salariale voilà donc je crois
que c'est un ensemble de choses on parle
là on est l'exemple tout à l'heure de
pouvoir d'achat ou du coût du carburant
il à la fois un débat sur les salaires
les rémunérations le le le prix de la
vie le coût de la vie on va en tous les
cas il ya un combat pour de mener
collectivement c'est le notamment toulon
ge pour autour de la pauvreté tout
l'enjeu autour des travailleurs pauvres
tout c'est un sujet qui est important
donc on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on a
besoin de remettre à plat un certain
nombre de sujets sur ce volet là et que
de ses efforts qu'ils sont doivent être
nécessaires l'écart dans tous les cas de
se réduire david guiraud vous dépeignez
un tableau très noir beaucoup des peines
mais c'est vrai qu'ils sont bien y avoir
un petit peu
deux approches alléché de l'insee tenez
qui nous disent et bien oui le
quinquennat maquereau a permis
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat même s'il
semblerait quand on regarde ça en valeur
absolue qu'il est davantage profité aux
plus aisés aux plus modestes mais vous
vous contestez clairement ces chiffres
on rappelle quand même quelques mesures
phares pas toutes les citer ici
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
de nombreux français
réduction d'impôt sur le revenu prime
d'activité pour beaucoup vous répondez
quoi c'est pas suffisant mais deux
choses c'est que d'abord ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que les mesures qu'on a
donnée aux plus riches sous ce
quinquennat c'est pour la vie et c'est
sans condition les mesures qu'on a
donnée aux plus pauvres c'est des
mesures de quoi de distribution entre
pauvres c'est à dire qu'en fait on va
supprimer des cotisations sociales pour
vous dire vous allez gagner du pouvoir
d'achat donc on supprime des cotisations
sociales et les cotisations sociales
elles sont utiles aux gens au moment de
partir à la retraite ou à l'assurance
chômage là on est en train de casser
l'assurance chômage donc si vous êtes
chômeur par un plat vous avez un emploi
on vous supprime votre cotisation
sociale vous gagnez un petit peu de
pouvoir d'achat allait d'accord mais si
vous êtes au chômage est bas vous fait
massacrer socialement c'est cela la
réalité de ces etc il y en a qui sont
vraiment sans condition pour la vie pour
l'ériger plus pour les pauvres vous
allez vers les habitations c'est sans
condition et 7 pour les
sections d'ailleurs
typiquement sur sur ces suppressions de
taxes je rappelle que pour les plus
pauvres le set sur le service public
c'est aussi un salaire c'est à dire que
le service public la gratuité de
certains éléments le fait que les avoirs
disponibles à côté de soi ça fait partie
de la vie des gens qui sont démunis dans
ce pays et quand vous justement retirer
certaines allocations à des
collectivités locales parce que la taxe
d'habitation c'est aussi ça on n'est pas
encore totalement de sur deux comment
l'état va compenser tout ça je veux dire
est ce qu'il va vraiment
pour l'excellence aujourd'hui c'est
clair et donc en tant qu en cd lui je
rendais faire son origine ont
aujourd'hui une compensation l'état donc
on voit bien que là il ya un choix
politique que je ne partage pas
forcément sur cette exonération mais que
en matière de moyens et de sa vie sa
portée pour auprès des collectivités
pour l'instant il n'y a pas d'inquiétude
labrecque qui sont la vraie question qui
évoquait c'est quand même la durée dans
la durée parce qu'on voit bien que on
est sur des actions plutôt court terme
qui sont souvent des actions qui stimule
d'ailleurs un quinquennat on manque de
vision plus globale et que d'autres
nuits jusqu'à demi million tous les cas
on règle pas le problème des
travailleurs pauvres le panneau pour le
problème de ceux qui sont juste à la
marge a vraiment donné pour lequel il
n'y a pas de musée l'accompagnement
suffisant voilà c'est un vrai sujet de
fond mais de nouveau je crois que
aujourd'hui c'est une vision globale
c'est les salaires c'est la capacité
aussi de maîtrise à sa tombe du coût de
la vie de tous les jours et puis ses
galons tout ce qui concerne notamment
les retraites on avait cet après midi un
texte sur l'allocation adulte handicapé
c'est un des sujets voilà de quoi bien
c'est une vision globale et par rapport
aux problématiques des recettes qui ne
rentrent plus notamment au niveau de
sécurité sociale c'est tout le débat de
la question je suis désolé ils sont
derrière vous me cherchez dépouillé mais
c'est vrai que ça revient souvent c'est
ses cotisations sociales ses ces taxes
qui plombe
là encore on n'a pas tout essayé parce
qu'il ya eu quand même des efforts de
consentis sur ce thème ces cotisations
sociales qui ont été tous même réduite à
vis de guy roux y met les cotisations
sociales fonds publics c'est du salaire
différé c'est du salaire que vous avez
après par exemple quand vous cotisez
pour votre retraite c'est vrai que sur
la feuille de paye ça vous ferait pas
plaisir mais quand vous êtes à la
retraite vous êtes content de partir à
la retraite et la réforme de justement
des retraites qui était prévu c'était le
fait de pouvoir crainte de devoir avoir
à travailler un deux trois quatre ans de
plus dans votre vie pour pouvoir
retrouver le niveau qu'on vous a volé
car c'est ça le truc donc quand on dit à
la presse nationale mais non mais vous
le disais quand vous êtes serait-ce
qu'un élan chauny semer ou vache on va y
arriver
une mouture pour moi loscos cotisent
pour certaines on côté pas pour sa
retraite on cotise pour le régime
général des retraites donc c'est une
approche différente
la nuance est quand même loin de vous
écrit que l'on devait travailler deux
ans de plus avec une réforme c'est aussi
pour nous qu on le fait mais je fais pas
trop l'idée des lacs d'antiques donc moi
je pense qu'il ya des leviers d'action
c'est pas vrai qu'il y en a pas on a
proposé une loi d'urgence sociale à la
faune sont soumises cette portée de ce
week-end est
donc le smic à 1400 euros net parce que
ça c'est une manière d'augmenter
directement les salaires pour les plus
petites entreprises qui auraient du mal
à trouver de la trésorerie qu'est ce
qu'on fait on fait un fond de solidarité
inter entreprises le but c'est que ce
soit les plus grandes entreprises qui
n'ont pas de mal à payer ses impôts là
qu'ils payent plus et les petites
entreprises qu'elles soient aidés par ce
fonds de solidarité pour équilibrer un
peu les efforts pour augmenter le smic
ça c'est pour le smic et maintenant on a
d'autres choses à faire on peut
augmenter les salaires de la fonction
publique parce que ça ça dépend de qui
de l'état on peut bloquer les prix des
prix de première des produits de
première nécessité c'est quelque chose
qu'il est possible de faire d'ailleurs
le gouvernement vient de le faire le cas
de problème fait vis-à-vis du gaz et de
l'électricité
mais il le fait une fois que la hausse a
eu lieu donc tout ça n'a aucun sens et
par ailleurs je le dis comme ça tant que
ce secteur sera de plus en plus
privatisé et qu'on a obéré obéira aux
règles de l'union européenne eh ben les
salles et les prix vont évoluer en
fonction de l'offre et la demande plus
d'un objet sa prose est marrant on va
passer la parole au niveau des mesures
notamment qui sont aujourd'hui portés
par l hypothèse bertrand lui 1 voilà ce
qui a comblé mais ça c'est un autre
débat veut augmenter de 200 euros les
travailleurs au smic via la prime
d'activité défiscalisation des heures
sup pour tout le monde y compris les
entreprises chez valérie pécresse rond
fait alors des globalement avant tout
sur le fait d'avoir une augmentation de
salaire pour les bas salaires jusqu'à
2,2 fois le smic l'idée c'est que on
puisse avoir plus de rémunération pour
les salariés mais pas content c'est une
baisse des charges salariales d'accord
donc là ça n'impacte pas directement
l'entreprise ses deux premiers volets
deuxième volet c'est de faire en sorte
que les salariés puissent participer
plus fortement au capital notamment des
grandes entreprises donc là on est sur
la participation keita 1 un principe
très gaulliste amour tout simple qui
pointent points importants et 3 ce guide
également la capacité à moment donné de
pouvoir avoir un peu alice âge dans la
durée notamment des efforts parce que
lorsque l'on fait un mort une
exonération masse salariale ça veut dire
que ce sont des cotisations qui rentrent
en moins et donc le grand débat de la
durée du temps de travail qui est un
point essentiel chez nous et notamment
d'avoir une capacité de flexibilité dans
les entreprises pour pardonner cette
capacité voilà donc ça c'est un des
différences fondamentales
mais là parce que
j'allais de cette fusion c'est vers le
financement évidemment nous mais c'est
justement le poème c'est que la manière
dont vous financer par exemple le fait
de gagner au pouvoir d'achat dans les
entreprises c'est de supprimer les
cotisations sociales mais encore une
fois les cotisations sociales c'est du
salaire différé c'est du salaire que
vous retrouvez dans votre vie quand vous
êtes en galère c'est ça la cotisation
sociale c'est je m'assure je m'assure en
cas de souci pour moi et en cas de souci
pour les autres et quand j'en ai besoin
je le reçois il ya des moments où vous
allez peut-être pas recevoir tel ou tel
rythme en fait si vous aussi vous briser
la jambe sur votre lieu de travail si
vous couper un doigt ou etc ça sera
quand même utile d'avoir cotisé fait
nuance quand même parce que l'idée c'est
que lorsque l'état
d'organiser des reines modifications sur
les cotisations sociales le possible de
la lauvette font que y ait une
compensation au plus ce sujet n'est pas
directement ce budget de la sécurité
sociale il est réellement sur le budget
général de l'état et donc ça renvoie à
la fois la capacité de réduire d'à côté
les bourses publiques mais surtout pour
nous la capacité de produire plus pour
créer de la richesse voilà donc à partir
de là on peut voir tous les grands
principes on sait qu'aujourd'hui le
principe général c'est comment on
retrouve de la richesse de ce pays est à
la fois la croissance pour la salsa
nombre de mesures qui dépasse le débat
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est également cette
notion de temps de travail qui est mené
mais fondamental c'est vrai qu'on parle
de jandin de la croissance mais enfin
c'est vrai que c'est assez poussif de
récupérer le bénéfice c'est ce que nous
dit d'ailleurs le mini de l'économie
aujourd'hui porté par cette croissance
fier de l'être ça ça va marcher mais la
croissance fin bon on a fermé le pays
pendant un an et demi on a tous fermés
et un jeu dit on à baisser les stores
allez tout le monde rentre chez lui donc
forcément la croissance a plongé on a
perdu je sais plus combien de % de
croissance 6,7 et là on nous dit mais
c'est génial la croissance augmente de
6% évidemment vu qu'on avait tous fermés
ça ne peut que augmenté mais cet
indicateur la n'a aucune valeur par
rapport à ce qui se passe vraiment dans
l'économie
mikati tout partout comme et non sur le
terrain on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui au
delà même du rattrapage par mois chez
toi j'ai eu mon territoire aujourd'hui
on est largement au dessus j'irai de des
carnets de commandes avant crise on voit
bien que l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est tout
sa capacité à trouver des travailleurs
dans les entreprises donc ça renvoie
d'abord le débat de l'attractivité des
métiers et de la rémunération donc voilà
donc on sent bien qu'aujourd'hui et
quand même évolution et la croissance à
votre métier t il pas dans les deux sens
c'était à que dès qu'on a une capacité
d'avoir un peu de croissance ça rentre
on fait rentrer des ddd cotisations
voilà donc voilà honnêtement moi je suis
vraiment vous vous leurrer si vous
pensez que là aujourd'hui les chiffres
de la croissance me le dire autre chose
que juste on a rouvert les entreprises
et donc forcément le chiffre de
l'activité parce que la croissance et ce
à sa mesure l'activité à la richesse de
ma région et moi on a tous fermés on a
tous rouverts donc forcément
statistiquement ça augmente mais par
contre il ya par exemple il ya des défis
concrets qui nous attendent par exemple
l'état a fait des prêts garantis vous
souvenez de salaire vient d'être prise
je la dette privée est en train
d'exploser et la dette privée
bah oui mais la dette privée je peux
vous dire que ces quelques milliards en
plus et le problème de la dette privée
c'est que autant qu'en l'état à une
dette on peut on peut s'arranger et
c'est avec les organismes internationaux
avec les banques quand c'est quelqu'un
qui ferme une entreprise une fois qu'ils
ferment il peut plus payer c'est fini de
rire quand il à 0 sur le compte en
banque c'est terminé et là c'est et
c'est ça qui est le plus dangereux donc
on a demandé et ça c'est une mesure
vraiment qu'on compte demande le
gouvernement devrait l'entendre et ça
devrait faire l'unanimité de reporter le
remboursement des prendre des prêts
garantis de l'état qui arrivent bientôt
à échéance et que plein de gens ne
pourraient pas payer et 6 pc la
fermeture est là je peux vous dire que
les chiffres de la croissance vous allez
rigoler quand vous allez les voir on a
vu à regarder alors c'est beaucoup de
deux truites à deux pas de tout et
excusez-moi de messages télégramme c'est
pas tout à fait pareil c'est surtout pas
le même support sortir de l'euro et de
l'ue c'est le rôle problèmes sont
souveraineté monétaire pas de pouvoir ça
revient souvent cette idée que bruxelles
mot coince un peu notamment sur le
pouvoir d'achat philippe mouillé sur ce
thème est ce que vous partagez ce
diagnostic de de nombreux alors moi je
ne partage pas et en même temps sur mon
road book de son boxer pour faire en
sorte que les taux d'intérêt de nos
prêts reste relativement bas donc un
moment donné on est contents de trouver
lorsqu'on a besoin d'outils
d'harmonisation ou deux pour 21 de temps
à niveau concernant les et ton intérêt
voilà donc pour moi le langer pas la
même si la réglementation européenne
elle pose des questions vous avez occupé
avons l'exemple d'électricité c'est un
bon exemple nous font croire que le
régime européen vous ou koné soit on est
une production d'électricité publique ou
prix ne soit pas le même c'est
complètement faux les règles
s'appliquent à tout le monde donc c'est
pas le statut d europe et donc c'est
pour ça qu'avant le discernement du
monopole d'edf semblait
dès lors que la commune son gré son
électricité s'engage autour de ça elle
est la capite de le faire donc chaud
qu'aujourd'hui il faut avoir en tête que
c'est parfois contraignant et notamment
en matière de normes à ya plein de sucre
ont fait la liste son déficit et entre
on peut mettre en avant et en même temps
lorsqu'on est sur des enjeux économiques
et notamment des hors-jeu pour maintenir
la situation générale on peut avoir
besoin de cet outil généraliser
ce qui se passe c'est que l'union
européenne libéralise des prix dans ce
qui vous arrive sur le gaz et l'énergie
c'est aussi une conséquence directe du
fait qu'on libéralise le système de
vente de production énergétique
c'est-à-dire qu'on donne au privé la
capacité de gérer les prix et le privé
ils feraient quoi il fait des bénéfices
qui regarde un truc tout simple l'offre
et la demande ils sont fous le privé de
savoir à ses pulsions sexuelles mondial
et je n'en veux pas je n'en veux pas aux
prix mais je veux dire c'est dans sa
nature de ne pas en avoir grand chose à
faire de l'utilité sociale d'une chose
mais des liens et à l'offre et la
demande et quand vous réfléchissez comme
ça et c'est le modèle que porte l'union
européenne c'est la libéralisation nos
essais sur la c'est le projet recul par
exemple très récemment projet recul qui
vise à découper edf en deux parties dont
la partie la plus rentable elle doit
priver toujours l'état se ramasse la
partie la moins rentable en au passage
mais le l'aboutissement de tout ça mais
vous l'avez vous avez des exemples
concrets au texas ils ont fait ça alors
c'est l'offre et la demande donc au
texas qu'est ce qui s'est passé
récemment il ya eu la vague de froid
vous l'avez vu donc les consommations
explosé et les jambes a vu que la
consommation exploser les prix ont
explosé et il se retrouve avec des
milliers d'euros de factures pour
quelques heures à peine 2
l'utilisation de l'électricité c'est ça
la libéralisation sereno ne réfléchit
pas l'incident mais si jamais cela est
essentiel donc aux nationalistes ou saas
et on évoque les son électricité c'est
tout le débat porte du nucléaire
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on se rend
compte qu'aujourd'hui le nucléaire est
nécessaire parce que emmène au delà des
enjeux le caractère décarbonés
rcc aussi clairement le débat sur les
tarifs et la métrite ait donc voilà donc
à part cela il ya des soit traitée gic
le problème c'est tout débat de
l'anticipation parce que là c'est comme
un paquebot à ce que prenait des
décisions et il faut les aider à voir le
retour est donc ça va partir en tout cas
des sujets sur la table mais le
nucléaire mais nucléaire mais ça coûte
plus cher que d'investir dans les
énergies renouvelables le nucléaire
c'est une énergie qui est finie on n'a
pas les deux clubs par attendait pas les
musées
ne vous fait pas fléchir votre
non non non je ne suis pas satisfait du
système actuel je pense pas qu'il faille
y retourner au charbon il peut faire les
choses de manière ordonnée et propre il
n'y a pas de problème mais il faut
parler avec sa crosse ainsi si le 2005
celle d'hermès jeunesse éduquée mais
c'est le problème attendez une aide
accrue suite non non on est en attendant
cette rapidité et je finis en recevant
une attaque son pouvoir et sa rapidité
c'est au sens propre sang de
renouvelables d'ici 2050 nous laisse un
peu de temps pardon hein maintenant je
vous dis le renouvela sur le nucléaire
le parc nucléaire il est fini y a que
deux choix y'en a pas 36 ans ou bien on
continue c'est à dire qu'on fait le
grand carénage notamment pour rénover
des centrales qui sont à bout de souffle
pour essayer de les permettre de
respirer donc on leur met le pacemaker
comme ça c'est ça on met un pacemaker
adea des industries nucléaires ça coûte
cent milliards d'euros selon la cour des
comptes 150 milliards seront selon
d'autres c'est extrêmement cher l'argent
qu'on investit dans le nucléaire en
faisant ça 1 euro vous l'utilisez qu'une
fois donc c'est de l'argent qu'on
investira pas dans la transition
écologique bien mais je dis ça parce que
tu ailles alors on va pas entamer le
débat c'est génial 30 mais ça sera
l'objet dans notre
pouvoir d'achat de 6 0 pour revenir à la
question de fond des choses c'est stylé
merci est donc un moment donné on est
vraiment sur ce sujet sur lequel on
attendait très rapidement c'est très
drôle comme la star deuxième par exemple
et on a fait les small nucléaire reactor
c'est quelque chose dont on nous dit que
ça pourra pas être vendu avant 2030 et
donc on pourra pas faire de production
en masse avant 2040 il paraît qu'à une
urgence écologique moi je suis désolé si
on parle de quelque chose qui n'est pas
prêt avant 2040 déjà c'est pas sérieux
leur but sera surtout des bottes 5,71 la
polka